لو كان الأمر كذلك لكانوا فيدان باين إيران
رحمة القلم في أذربيجان دائما
إعادة الجندي إلى أفعاله بقلم ذ
على سبيل المثال ، كليمون ، أليس كذلك؟
أنا أعاني وهذه الأخت إيراني لطيفة
تاهيم أذربيجان الفتح بالفستق
اسرائيل سلمت من القوة لكنها مريحة
بالفعل العسكرية يا فاتوف تنفيذ أسيلو اللعنة
لدي بالفعل مفاتيح الكوفي أكفات لهم
ينام ببطء فيلم مصطفى كمال avrat
التلحي بالعقاب ، أطنان من الكراهية
واو بعد دقائق Mu Drachoma للرقم
أنت تنام أكثر حتى فيلم دورتك المحتارة
دا مدرسة هادي على ميرامينا
يمكن أن تعزز تصبح أفضل جوني
بالله من الفى الصلاة حتى فالنسيا
وصل Danisiks إلى Buse على رف Atlético
ما هيك كل لحم هنغاري حقًا
قاتلة وحي لها سها تأتي على إيران علي
لا يعرفك أكساراي ، لذلك أذربيجان
فائض تعيين الامي حق ديني
hanehou reasoni الكيلومتر المكروه
على الفور أو أي golem tek tefibi
المرقبات لكن اغمق الليمون العورات
تركيا الكوفية تسمع الأسئلة مرة أخرى
قافية المصطلح الإيراني Halfeti الأرمني
فيلم Rıdvan Elif ludima تركيا و
ألوم الجهاز الذي أدخل إيران في هذا الأمر.
ولكن مصطلح لشجرة أحادية أو شيء من هذا القبيل
مياه أذربيجان وتركيا من الفندق إلى القلعة
شاهين مونت عنوان اختبار الصلة من الخلف
ملجأ سيفرق ديدم الزي القاعدة
اغتصاب شقيق محافظة قونية أذان كل
هناك انتم اذربيجان وايران
اللحوم المجمدة biocat ليست رقيقة على أي حال
لم يأكل قسر إيراني وطن غير صالح للأكل حلو
كنت سأصطحب خالتي لتتدحرج على هذه الخطوة
أعلن